cédric 30 ans et sergent chef au 21e
régiment d'infanterie de marine
donc deux minutes aujourd'hui il doit
reprendre ce village tomber entre les
mains des insurgés
mais l'ennemi opposent une forte
résistance
ils sont chiants ils arrivent à stopper
la situation il arrive à le ralentir
dans notre progression donc c'est
excessivement énervant
pour l'emporter ils pourront compter sur
les conseils de miguel un soldat rompus
au combat en zone urbaine en afrique et
au moyen-orient
continue lagarde
parviendront-ils à rester en vie
ce matin cédric est en première ligne si
vous avez vous assurez ouverture du feu
engagé depuis plus de dix ans ce chef de
groupe revient d'une opération en
afrique
l'ennemi connaît les lieux par coeur les
soldats qui attaquent doivent être
vigilants dans bâtiment 0,5 actuellement
g3 personnel vivant le restant du groupe
est décédé
à l'arrière des combats dans son
véhicule blindé le capitaine éric note
les pertes subies et coordonne la tacc
de ses troupes a ébloui qu est ce que tu
es en mesure de déclencher un tir là sur
ce char région fut de espagne
pour le commandant la situation commence
à devenir préoccupante moi ce que
j'espère c'est avoir le moins de pertes
possibles puisque à partir du moment où
je perds des hommes la capacité des
sections diminue et donc à partir de là
on n'est plus en mesure de remplir la
mission est en face la force des
adversaires les très bien organisé
selon les règles de l'armée française
pour remporter une bataille en zone
urbaine il faut être au minimum six fois
plus nombreux que l'adversaire
sans cela la vente âge donné par le
terrain est insurmontable
malgré cette écrasante supériorité
numérique cédric et son équipe sont
mises en difficulté
ça vous placer leurs fumigènes donc
c'est
je trouve ça guérit
connais très bien la zone d'où la
difficulté pour nous de main d'oeuvre et
de les surprendre ils sont battables ils
sont battables personne qui est
imbattable le truc c'est arrivé à
retrouver la santé plus facile à dire
qu'à faire et tu m'a plu je montais vrai
1 2 3 des soldats ne progressent presque
jamais par les rues principales trop
dangereuse dès qu'ils le peuvent ils
passent de maison en maison à travers
des trous dans les murs il s'apprête à
s'emparer du dernier bâtiment
sur deux trop sûrs d'eux l'offensive est
un échec
cédric et inde m mais beaucoup de
soldats sont morts ou gravement blessée
qu'est les hautes capacités
opérationnelles aux indices étaient là à
l'heure actuelle il me reste grosso modo
une section tour
s'il rassemble tous les élèves